and your calves are burning and you're
shaking and I love it I am shaking just
Selena shake
I want the Selena shake you are the Guru
hot Pilates everyone wants a nice little
juicy booty I'm known as the booty
ologist over here in LA the natural way
can you break down exactly why hot good
to detox you have to sweat it out it
intensifies the workout it decreases the
warmup time as well then you kind of
push yourself a little bit more without
over stretching your body how hot
exactly does the room get 95 degrees
I don't throw that's like a day in LA I
am so much you have amassed an
incredible celebrity following perhaps
the most notable might be Selena Gomez
and I just look good for you good for
you uh-huh
how did you get to know her when did you
guys first link up we've been working
together for about three years but
sometimes I feel like she's my bigger
sister she's literally the biggest
sweetheart I mean no one works harder
than this girl and she works out this
girl is focused Selena came with Justin
and he took a class here together lots
of ads they love their abs workout lots
of stretching so Posse sweating
[Music]
I want the three essential Selena Gomez
moves that I have to do to get her
rocking pilates body 10 we do it
absolutely my favorite parts let's get
to it
bring your legs wide as wide as you can
point your toes out connect to that core
already your brain is in your stomach
bend your knees bring your tailbone
straight down use your stomach nice now
squeeze your inner thighs to come up
stand nice and tall and bring it down
and squeeze it up and one hold it down a
lot of girls tend to poke the butt out
here save that for the club a little
booty pop a little booty poppin always
good from here use your stomach can you
pulse down four five and four good three
nice really feel it right and one hold
it can you lift your right heel up and
then lift your left heel up the feet or
your foundation with your feet to warm
up and now pulse to good deidre so now
you're working your inner thighs your
glutes your stomach abs are tighter and
your calves are burning and you're
shaking and I love it I am shaking just
Selena shake I want the Selena shake
[Music]
music's got me going so 10 reps of each
one set one round okay shoulders roll
back down your back good use your core
deep in the stomach and then use your
core to lift you nice and tall good the
brain is now in your butts okay focus on
that muscle part that you're working so
that mind-body connection
you don't leave a body part at home
either so we add efficient workouts
movements like combining multiple muscle
parts now let's add the ABS add the arms
stand tall
give me a bicep curl balance nice bring
it back into a lunge good let's do four
more just five of these is good for my
main cue that I always go back to is
shoulders back and down away from the
ears lengthening the back of your neck
so your spine is nice and neutral a girl
likes to push that booty out but we're
gonna build you a butt you know to push
it out
so tailbone is long and then most
important one stomach in using your abs
to push up and down try to think of a 1
and as they take one curl away a day so
maybe today you focus on your shoulders
maybe you focus on your tailbone focus
on the booty your focus on the booty
it's 95 degrees in here it is no joke
we've done like two moves and I'm
profusely sweating your workout is no
joke you are getting hot okay I'm ready
to have my Selena bod by summer third
move so extend your legs all the way out
this one sculpts those beautiful long
legs slim those hips so reach your arms
all the way down hands behind your head
your top arm is in front of your stomach
keep your balance bring your top legs
nice and long okay now from here point
your toe try to rotate internally the
muscle so you're working from the glutes
and not from your quads right reach your
legs all the way up to the sky and flex
your heel down and reach and point and
reach and flex and exist resist and do
ten of these for ten and extend and nine
okay so I'm getting a little tired here
what's something that you say to Selena
to kind of keep her motivated when maybe
her muscles are about to like fatigue
and go out I'll stop I think just
knowing that you're at the end at this
playing your echo you should be so
connected so strong and muscles are
completely in sync with your mind and
really just feeling amazing you know so
I'm knowing that you're about to finish
and hold it for one point your toes do
circles and then breathe into the hip
try to keep your pelvis stable your abs
tight using your butt to work and then
let's reverse it and stretch and keeping
your knees soft so you're working we'll
go into the back side and two and one
go bring your legs together let's hug
your knees into your hips 90 degrees
take your hand onto your hip create your
own resistance press that on your leg
and resist it up and resist it down for
ten use your stomach and nine
and a always the same for things
shoulders back and down
scoop abs tight lengthen the back of
your neck let's bring your feet in the
air little clamp for 10 and outer thighs
are burning burning so we work the inner
thigh work the outer thigh always work
the body with balance and hold it do you
have a kick in you
I sure let's kick it up and fir floor
can you kick from your stomach and two
and one bring it down shake it out
give us something rooted in the stomach
makes it so much more challenge I do get
that mentality in a p-card it's hard to
not use your core Shannon I'm out of
breath
I'm exhausted I'm drenched but I feel
like a million bucks we're really killed
with it oh my God thank you so much for
your instruction the mind body soul
connection of this workout is truly like
no other do you think I'm gonna have a
Selena Gomez bod by summer 1000% and
date to it I will and do you think
Selena would be proud 100% we're making
Selena proud over here you guys check
out Shannon she teaches here at her
studio hot Pilates in West Hollywood it
is no joke
come prepared and we'll see you next
time
[Music]